[Music]
foreign
then for the Press preview it's our
first look at Sunday's front pages and
tonight we'll be looking at those
headlines with the guardian's political
correspondent our letter Adu and the
editor of the Jewish Chronicle Jake
Wallace Simons we'll chat to them in a
moment but we'll show you the front
pages before we do that starting with
the Sunday Express which has word of a
new government initiative designed to
tackle anti-social Behavior by making
people convicted of it where uniforms
wash police cars and clean up graffiti
the paper says it's designed to win back
voters in the northern red wall seats
while the mail on Sunday reports that
the Prime Minister intends to let
victims of such crimes have a say in how
perpetrators are punished
here's the Observer leading with a sting
by the campaign group led by donkeys in
which the former Health secretary Matt
Hancock and the former Chancellor
quasiquarteng were filmed asking for ten
thousand pounds a day to carry out work
for a fake South Korean firm there's no
suggestion they or two other
conservative MPS who had interactions
with the imposters did anything illegal
and Sky News has contacted all of them
for comment
meanwhile the Sunday Telegraph
understands the Home Secretary swella
bravaman could soon block injunctions by
the European Court of human rights to
stop flights carrying migrants being
deported from leaving the UK
the Sunday people speaks to a former
Royal Protection Officer who once
guarded the Princess of Wales and says
he fears there are more officers out
there like convicted murderer Wayne
cousins who are still on the beat
a report from the children's
commissioner seen by the Sunday Times is
expected to claim that children as young
as eight have been strip searched by the
police
and the Sunday Mirror hears from
Strictly Come Dancing judge Shirley
balance about her experiences with
social media trolls
I don't forget you can scan the QR code
that you see on screen during the
program check out the front pages of
tomorrow's papers while you watch us
discussing them and to chat about them
Lita Adu and Jake Wallace Simon's great
to see you this evening thank you for
spending your Saturday evening with us
lots to talk about in Sunday's papers
um let's start with this story on the
front of the Sunday Express announced
this evening that the prime minister is
going to crack down on anti-social
behavior
um a letter what did you make of this
it's quite interesting that he's
deciding today to lead on this given
Tomorrow there's going to be a huge
debate in the House of Commons
on you know his immigration proposals
but nevertheless also quite interesting
that the prime minister is deciding to
speak to you know a large proportion of
his voters uh via the mail and the
express discussing this big crime plan
that really isn't anything new to be
honest he's announcing plans to give
communities their say on how you know
anti-social Behavior could be tackled
within our communities
um it's almost echoing customers
proposals to ensure that a labor
government would take you know such
crimes and penalty youth extremely
seriously but it's quite interesting
that you know when kissed armor
announced
uh his plans there this week and it
wasn't met with that much uh you know
Goodwill let's say because a lot of
people were claiming that he wasn't
tackling the important crimes let's say
and social behavior was one of the
Lesser ones
um but also interesting again uh the
Prime Minister seems to be following
seems to be clearly worried that you
know people are you know taking a listen
to you know what the labor leader has to
say and he's also announcing his plans
to um I mean again you know we heard of
Boris Johnson you know announcing so
many ideas on big big ideas and how to
tackle crime and nothing really came out
of it
um it'll be interesting to see what the
Prime Minister thinks he can do within
the next year um I don't think this is a
way of really you know cutting back and
keeping people safe keeping women and
girls safe that he is really yet to
um set out how exactly he can do and
maybe anesthetical behavior is something
that he feels uh he might be able to
achieve before he before the next
election yeah um the Express and also
the mail on Sunday Jake are splashing on
this set the mail going uh with the
angle that
um those offenders who are put to work
are going to have to clean up their
crimes within 48 Hours of being handed
their uh punishments and also that the
victims will get it saying what they
have to do what do you think about that
that's right and the other eye-catching
detail is that the perpetrators may be
forced to wear shaming jumpsuits so the
community can see them while they're
cleaning their graffiti off walls or
whatever this does seem like a um
another red meat move that Richard sunak
is making and combined with the
migration bill that's uh being go
through Parliament tomorrow it does
appear that he's making a concerted
effort to win back the red wall voters
and you know the problem that the Tory
has always faced is that you've got the
red wall voters in the north uh with
whom you're competing for let with labor
and then you've got the lib Dem swing
seats in the South who are more
liberal-minded and it's very difficult
to win one and win the other one as well
so it seems like Rishi really is going
for this strategy of of the north of
introducing some really hard sort of hot
um Tory uh policies in order to win
votes uh up there to my taste this does
feel a little bit much I mean the idea
of dressing people up in John suits and
shaming them as they as they clean
graffiti does feel a little bit medieval
but um but you know I think it will
appeal to people who really suffer from
antisocial behavior in their local
communities uh particularly up north
okay let's move on to the front of the
uh Observer um a letter and this sting
um which uh shows that quasi-quartering
also Matt Hancock two other MPS as well
agreed to work for uh 10 000 pounds a
day certainly Hancock and quote to
further the interests of this fake South
Korean firm
um so it is a sting in one sense but
actually uh none of the four did
anything wrong as far as I'm aware
no they didn't actually uh you know
break any rules but I mean it's still an
interesting uh investigation led by the
campaign group led by donkeys they
essentially posed as a fake South Korean
company and approached these four MPS
you know the former Chancellor
quasi-quarting Matt Hancock Stephen
Hammond and the chairman of the 1922
committee sir Graham Brady at a time
when you know the cost of living crisis
continues to deepen people are
continuing to struggle with inflation
still being incredibly High despite the
prime minister's pledges and missions
and you know vows to you know tackle it
and cut it as soon as possible and we've
got quasi-quarting and Matt Hancock
green to you know further the interest
of this firm for ten thousand pounds
um remarkable given at around this time
when this when the uh the by donkeys
campaign group approached the MPS
Hancock's a big WhatsApp uh reveals had
been published by the telegraph that put
the government's handling of covid under
intense scrutiny but if you see there
are videos of this that have been posted
on Twitter I believe and he seems pretty
calm seems pretty you know relaxed about
everything that's going on and he's
instantly you know reacting to questions
about fees and coming up with these
incredible figures
um I mean it must be noted that a labor
labor has you know promised to scrap uh
second jobs for MPS if they come into
power
um again it must be noted that they
didn't agree to work for this fate firm
but I just think it's quite interesting
that you know such striking figures I
mean Sarah gray and Brady agreed to work
for six thousand pounds um you know the
work of an MP is incredibly difficult
people are going through a lot of
difficult times at the moment
um and yet you know we're still seeing
them agreeing for such high fees I think
you know it must be investigated
um also must be mentioned I think at
regards of this month some new rules
came into play that would stop MPS
completely you know advising other firms
which none of them did but you know why
why should they be able to claim ten
thousand pounds just for you know
showing up in South Korea essentially
it's quite remarkable yeah good to get
your thoughts on this uh Jay because
um as we were hearing no suggestion of
any wrongdoing in fact Stephen Stephen
Hammond has told the paper that um South
Korea is a country that's close to my
heart I've got a substantial Korean
community in my constituency it's an
important Ally to the UK
um obviously it was a a fake company I
suppose the issue is whether MPS should
be allowed to do outside work for you
know um quite a lot of cash
that's right I mean Matt Hancock is in
my view one of the most repellent people
in public life so I'm not really Keen to
defend him
um or indeed uh the other figures
involved however uh I'm I find it a bit
of a stretch this story because these
people didn't do anything wrong and if
somebody comes to you and offers you a
job for ten thousand pounds a day you'd
be a fool to say no uh you know Matt
Hancock and Graham Brady who's the other
person who was involved in this sting
both of them are leaving Parliament uh
after the next election so it's
reasonable for them to look at what's
going to come next how they can develop
new relationships and new jobs and and
make money and everybody wants to make
money I think there's a single viewer at
home who would turn down 10 grand a day
if it was offered to them
they weren't uh approached with ten
thousand pounds they themselves offered
the fear they're actually the the
campaigners suggested a salary range
between eight and sixteen thousand I
think they went for this 10 grand in the
middle so it did originally come from
the campaigners
um but I think that the wider issue you
is the is second jobs as a whole if they
are a good idea at the moment there are
no rules or regulations governing second
jobs for MPS they're allowed to have
them and there are two potential
problems that come from that one is the
amount of time they might spend on
second jobs rather than serving their
constituencies and the other is the
potential for conflict of interest so I
think all this points really to the need
for regulation and for some kind of
guidelines for MPS they know exactly uh
what to do
okay
um let's move on to the front of the
standard Telegraph we've already touched
on the the migrant story
um uh a letter the Home Secretary could
ban the European Court of human rights
from grounding those Rwanda flights
um in order to quell this Rebellion that
uh the government's going to see next
week
yes
over the last week specifically on this
particular amendment of this illegal
migration bill that's currently going
through the commons and a lot of them
are extremely worried about you know
their future a lot of them are worried
that they're going to end up within you
know the next year or 18 months you know
working for some smaller accountant
public firm public media firms sort of
lining up jobs as uh we were sort of
alluding to in the in the previous story
because Richie Cena vowed he promised
the country that he will stop the boats
he will stop all boats you know arriving
um at the channel who you know make it
really difficult for people to claim
Asylum even victims of modern slavery
people that have really struggled as a
result of you know our previous
government's interferences and their
countries you know won't go into too
much detail on there but they are coming
here to seek refuge and the Prime
Minister has insisted you know he will
try and stop that in order to help his
government get a grip on what is a
failure and then in you know handling uh
applications let's say
um and a lot of them are worried that
they just won't have enough time to to
complete this Mission before the next
election so we've got a number of Red
Bull Tory MPS who are now you know
threatening to Rebel we've got at least
60 Tories now as I reported on Friday
essentially saying to Rishi like you
need to really you know come up with the
toughest stance within this bill and
they believe that the tough stance would
be to block uh the to block judges from
being able to Grant injunctions to to
prevent people from being deported again
it's really outrageous there are a
number of moderate Tories that are you
know disagreeing with this and it won't
be taking part in these in these votes
on these particular amendments but Rishi
really has a problem on his hands
um you know he first referring red meat
around him and Sue Ella Bradman are
equally as guilty is doing this it's
really not enough to tackle the matter
of fact that they're just not processing
Asylum applications enough why are
people being left in hotels for
well for months up to years I know it's
people that helped our government in in
operations when we were in need of help
why can they not have a safe route to
come to this country why are there no
say fruits and there are a number of
amendments that have been proposed by
Tories as well as opposition parties to
encourage the government to create safe
routes so people are not making a
horrible decision to come on onto into
into our country via you know this
difficult and tragic Journey but whether
I'm sorry to wrap you up we're out of
Time Jake I'll get your thoughts on this
story
um uh next hour if that's okay we do
need to move on but thank you both for
the moment coming up after the break a
new report is expected to claim that
children as young as eights have been
strip searched by the police we'll
discuss that and more next
[Music]
hello again part two of The Press
preview Elita and Jake are still with us
uh Jake front of the Sunday Times I mean
this story sounds horrific children are
routinely being stopped and strip
searched by police according to a new
report
that's right I mean coming after all the
recent Revelations about
um abuse within the Metropolitan Police
in particular and other forces as well
this really comes as a very very
depressing development 3 000 children
have been strip searched over the last
four uh years in England and Wales
um about a quarter of them are between
the ages of 10 and 15 with a small
number as young as eight uh and black
kids are six times as likely to be strip
searched as white children
um all of this is as I say the most
depressing development on the police
story there have been lots of calls for
root and Branch reform of the police
both the armed units and other units as
well
um after the revelation of their
WhatsApp conversations containing racist
and misogynistic content
um and now this does seem to be an
endemic problem of strip searching
children uh if you recall some time ago
there was a girl a black girl who was
strip searched while on her period and
that created a great Channel but it now
seems as if it's almost a systematic
practice that really does need to be
addressed as soon as possible yeah Lee
talk to you what do you make of this um
the children's commissioner commissioner
calling on police Chiefs to to get their
act together
yes and yeah we've got our prime
minister on this remarkable crime Blitz
trying to trying to view a particular
portion of the country in order to save
his job
we had one of the most uh horrifying and
damning reports from Louise Casey you
know outlining the the horrific
practices of the Met police you know
casting them as institutionally racist
sexist and homophobic as you know we all
knew I don't think anyone was surprised
by that and yet with in line with these
horrifying statistics also from Rachel
de Cesar we're still not hearing
anything really from the Prime Minister
like directly from the Prime Minister he
could have used today's papers the
chance to do that and he has refused to
do so why is that um I think many people
at home would be thinking
yeah the the the Met Commission of
course um accepting the findings but uh
uh saying he didn't believe that uh the
problems were institutional
um let's move on to this story Jake in
the express
um following on from
um the kings first overseas trip to
France being canceled
yes the um the express is suggesting
that the real reason why the um the
French canceled the king's trip was
because he was scheduled to have a some
Jewish banquet uh in Paris and the the
images of that would have really wound
the country up even more than they are
already we're seeing riots all over
France some really quite serious riots
um uh missiles being thrown
um fires being lit we've had some quite
serious injuries sustained by protesters
including one who lost a finger another
Who Lost His sight with a stunned
grenade being fired by police and all
this is part of uh discontent in France
not just at the attempt to raise the
retirement age by two years to 64. and
but also on the whole the the sort of
poor level of Public Services
um and a PR and a president who's out of
touch public services in France France
is the highest taxed country in Europe
and they expect their public services to
be decent and they're just not trains
are always late things aren't working in
front rounds and meanwhile macron has
this sort of technocratic career civil
servant manner that really gets up the
nose of the French and this is the
results
Elita
I just think it would have been quite
nice to hear from some sort of Palace
official expressing their you know
sadness and you know possible the fact
that it's not a great situation out in
France apart from the fact that oh the
the attempts to continue this French UK
relationship has been postponed it was
quite it wasn't the best statement in my
opinion and you know lacked a bit of
empathy animation there yeah okay let's
have a look at this uh story as well
about Agatha Christie it's uh on the
front of the telegraph
um I mean it follows on from a from a
number of such stories Jake doesn't it
of late including sort of Roald Dahl
yeah I find this really appalling
actually the way that um modern editors
feel that they can ride a coaching
horses through some classic works of
literature and change them according to
Modern sensibilities or some Modern
sensibilities Agatha Christie is the
best-selling author ever she's second
only to Shakespeare in terms of sales
and now her um pyro and um and Miss
Marple books are being edited heavily uh
on on the advice of sensitivity readers
without people being told about it so if
you pick up your Kindle and download a
poro story it'll be different to what
Agatha Christie originally intended and
this is all very disturbing it it uh it
it presents a sort of whitewashing of
the past you know how do we how are we
able to learn from our history and to
move on
um if our history is being edited
retrospectively and the literature that
goes with it as well it all seems like
an attempt to really you know sort of
infantilize the public and prevent them
from coming across anything nasty I mean
some of the examples are really absurd
that we're edited out and so it's all
very indeed
yeah I'm just trying to trying to find
some of the examples it says here
stripping the works of numerous passages
containing descriptions insults or
references to ethnicity particularly for
characters that Christie's protagonists
meet outside the UK
um what do you think Elita
now I completely agree with Jake
actually it is incredibly worrying and
it does as he said seem like uh the
public is being infantilized I think yes
absolutely you know maybe some sort of
annotation marks could have been added
in place of just literally editing
chunks out and changing what uh Christie
would have written in order to preserve
that history and we could have compared
to see with what you know they would
have suggested
um but yeah it's I mean let's remember
like books are also essentially like a
form of art as well is that what
Christie would have wanted her art to be
of left as
um it's just really disappointing that
we're seeing this flurry of you know
really respected novels
um she's not the first this has happened
to in the last few months
um just being completely wiped out
essentially yeah interesting uh to get
your views thank you very much speak to
you again in an hour